Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
You would pose some questions.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
Living Tissue Sepsis
is brought to you by wordpress.
My goto platform for blogging,
writing online, creating
websites, everything.
I love wordpress to bits.
My site,
every site just about that I have is run
on wordpress and the lead developer of
wordpress, Matt Mullenweg has
appeared on this podcast many times.
The very first episode
in particular is amazing.
The second I took a ton of notes on,
so he's checking out, but wordpress,
where do I even begin? I mean the
New Yorker uses it, Jay z, Beyonce,
they use it. Five 38
tech crunch, Ted, CNN.
Time with you are looking to create
a personal blog, a business site,
both, neither. Something else.
You'll make a huge impact when you
build your website on wordpress.com and
directly from some friends at Google.
I'm not going to quote them by name,
but they say that wordpress offers
the best out of the box SEO.
That's search engine optimization
imaginable. So if you're on wordpress,
you immediately have a leg up on everybody
else on search engines and so forth.
In my experience, I'm no medical
doctor of search engine optimization,
but I will say that I used wordpress for
years and fell in love with it to the
extent that I became very close friends
with Matt and then became an investor
slash advisor to automatic
which runs wordpress doc on.
That is how much I believe in this and
that's how a lot of my most successful
products and investments have come about
because I'm in love with x and then I
seek out x.
Nearly 30% of the Internet
is run on wordpress and that
includes everything from
the huge sites that I mentioned to
neighborhood sites and it is super easy to
get started. There's no need to worry
about security or upgrades or hosting.
They offer 24 seven support and handle
all of that which allows you to focus on
creating the highest quality content
that you can with the least amount of
friction.
I don't have to worry about downtime.
I don't want to have to
worry about getting emergency
emails if I'm on vacation
or something like that, and wordpress
is my goto solution for all of this.
I trust all of my most important
text on the Internet to wordpress,
and they can't buy that with
a sponsorship. They can't
buy that with anything.
I want uptime, uptime,
uptime, and quality,
and that is what I have selected
after everything that I've looked at.
So check it out.
Go to wordpress.
That's w o r d p r e s.com wordpress.com
forward slash Tim to receive 15% off of
your website today.
That's wordpress.com forward slash
Tim
this episode is brought to you by audible,
which I've used for many, many years.
I absolutely love audio books and there
one of my favorite ways to pass the time
when I travel.
I'm on the road all the time and audible
allows me to consume many more books
than I possibly could otherwise I have
to audio books to recommend right off the
bat. The first is perhaps my
favorite audio book of all time.
It's the only audio book I've
wanted to listen to twice in a row.
The graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
It's amazing and you will thank me.
There are a few different versions.
I like the version that
Neil narrates himself,
one of the most soothing
voices of all time.
The second book is vagabonding
by Rolf Potts, p, O, t t, s,
which had a huge impact on my life and
formed the basis for a lot of what would
later become the four hour workweek,
so go to audible.com forward slash Tim
and you can choose one of these two books
or any of many, many other options
that could be books, magazines,
and much more as a listener
of the Tim Ferriss show,
you can also access a free 30 day trial.
Just go to audible.com forward slash.
Tim You can't make more time,
but you can make the most of it.
So turn your travel or your commute
into something more with a free trial at
audible.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim to
start now and get your free 30 day trial.
Low boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct world class
performers, to tease out the habits,
routines, favorite books, breakfasts,
whatever it might be that you can
test and apply in your own life,
the specifics, the details,
the beliefs, habits,
and so on that you can
actually use in the real world.
And this episode we have a fantastic
guest I've wanted to connect with for a
very long time. Darren
Aronofsky. So who is Darren,
we're going to get to that in a second,
but he was introduced to me
by another podcast guest,
Peter Attia who is a medical doctor,
an endurance athlete or he would
say former endurance athlete.
And I encourage you to also check out
his episodes because it'll put a lot in
context and Peter has three episodes.
If you just go to tim.blog
forward slash a tia, a, t, t I a,
you will find three of them. They start
with doctor Peter Tia on life extension,
drinking jet fuel, ultra endurance,
human foie gras and more too.
The next one, optimizing
investing blood hormones and life.
Then my life extension pilgrimage
to Easter island. It's a long story,
but check it out. Tim. Dot blog forward
slash at Tiaa, but back to Darren,
Darren Aronofsky. You can find them
on Twitter and Instagram at Darin,
d a r r e n Aronofsky a r o n o f s k
y to say hello and he's doing some very
cool stuff on Instagram
and Darren aronofsky.com is
the founder and head of the
production company,
protozoa pictures.
He is the acclaimed in award winning
filmmaker behind cult classics like Pi
Requiem for a dream and the wrestler
which are really just the tip of the
iceberg when it comes to his filmography,
but going back to the beginning pie,
his first film,
that was 1998 one him early plots and
he best director award at the Sundance
Film Festival.
Aronofsky.
That's Daren later directed and produced
the wrestler which I absolutely loved
and made its world premiere
at the Venice Film Festival,
which happens to be the oldest film
festival in the world where it became only
the third us film in history when
the esteemed Golden Lion Award,
Darren leader directed the Indy box
office phenomenon, Black Swan, which one?
Natalie Portman,
the Academy Award for best actress and
Garner for other Oscar nominations,
including best picture
then is the inspired epic.
Noah opened at number one at the box
office and grossed more than 362 million
worldwide.
His latest movie,
his mother with lowercase
m and an exclamation point,
a psychological horror thriller film
starring Jennifer Lawrence, Javier Bardem,
ed Harris, Harrison, many others,
Michelle Pfeiffer. It goes on.
I've had a chance to see this movie and
I'm stumbling over my words because it's,
it's hard to describe.
It was mind bending,
super intense.
And I walked around in a dream state
for an entire day after seeing this.
It is unlike anything you
have ever seen. So, uh,
if you want to strap on your seat
belt and go on a roller coaster,
I suggest that you check it out.
So without further ado,
please enjoy my conversation
with Darren Aronofsky.
Darren, sir, welcome to
the show. Thank you Tim.
I have been looking forward to meeting
you for some time now, but thank you.
I'm a big fan as well.
We have quite a few mutual friends
and I have some suggestions.
I won't mention them by name
yet as to topics and questions,
but I wanted to start with a question
about your writing environment.
Oh, that's a good question. I've read
a little bit about a desk. You will,
your desk,
could you describe this desk
and if you still use it,
it was interesting.
I know you've spent time in Japan and
so I was in Japan probably promoting,
I don't know if it was pio requiem for a
dream and I went to some spa town south
of Tokyo,
I can't remember the name of it.
And I guess it was the kind of nexus of
this place where they make these puzzle
boxes. I don't know if you've ever
seen them. They're kind of beautiful.
Pattern would inboxes and you can't
really see any hinges or any spaces,
but if you slide a few panels in a
certain order and it could be up to eight
1632 moves depending on how
much money you want to spend.
Eventually it opens and as a secret
compartment. And it blew my mind.
I had never seen any
type of souvenir like it.
I bought a couple and I played with it
for a long time and then I think it was
early days of Internet. So I started to
Google a little bit about what it is.
There's a whole art form,
I won't try to butcher
the Japanese word for it,
but I then noticed that there were
contests worldwide and that there was,
there was this one dude who was winning
year after year contest and he was a guy
in Colorado. So I was like,
oh, that's kind of interesting.
And so just randomly I tracked
them down and I sent him an email,
his name's Kagan sound and I sent
him an email. I said, hey, you know,
did you ever think of doing any
furniture? And he's like, well, actually,
I'm working on this thing for
a library. And I said, well,
it'd be interesting maybe to do a
desk out of it. And He loved the idea.
And um, then he, it was amazing
and he said it true master. I May,
we should probably go over to my house
to check it out. I would love to say it.
David saw it. I don't a if he
told you about it, but he freaked
the hell out. David Blaine. Yeah. This
is, this is part of why I'm asking.
Oh, okay, got it. Yeah. So anyway,
uh, he ended up this, this master,
so the whole thing is made
it completely out of wood.
He doesn't work with any other
materials but would, and um,
I'm not sure the count on
puzzles in the desk, but it's,
I mean,
scores of them.
And eventually they all sort of work
together to build to a final release where
you basically, it, he was able to
turn it into a musical instrument.
He created bellows all
controlled with wood.
And the draws and by
actually pushing the draws,
it create sounds and it has a full octave.
And he asked me what song I wanted and
it has, he been, was able to build a,
basically a computer thing that has
switches that are all blown by the bellows
and if they're done in the right order,
a panel flaps open in the
back with a secret draw.
So it took him five years
to do it and it was insane.
And I think the price we agreed on was
a crime at the beginning cause I am to
him or driving him.
It was a cry that him and I felt so.
And then I realized I didn't have a
chair for it. So then I said, you know,
we should make a puzzle chair for it
and that and then out years later and I
paid through the nose for
that to get them back. But um,
it's a beautiful thing
and it's a great desk.
I want to say,
I read this in a previous interview that
you've referred yourself as a nomadic
writer or writing in one place for a
few weeks and then moving locations.
So how does your writing process
differ project to project or do you,
how do you use,
say the desk that we were just talking
about and combine that with shifting
locations?
I'm on book deadline right now,
so I'm thinking about this and of course
I'll do anything to avoid writing.
Exiting,
including interviews.
Exactly. Um, I, I completely understand
that procrastination, but you know,
my a writing partner,
a guy right with a lot already handled
once said to me probably the most
important thing I taught to him taught
him was that I didn't do this on purpose,
is that procrastination
is part of the process.
That actually your brain needs
a break every once in a while.
And not to say to abuse that,
but to be a little easy on yourself and
allow yourself to go to a bookstore,
to go to a museum to just,
even if you are serious about your work,
even when you're not working,
you're, you are working,
your brain is putting stuff
together and you know,
inspiration comes from the strangest
places as we all know. You know,
you suddenly stumble on something that's
exactly what you were looking for when
you didn't know you were looking for it.
But it's changed.
My writing process I used to,
what I do was a tremendous amount of prep
where we would do a tremendous amount
of research and outlines and eventually
get to a place where were we?
We were exhausted with that and then
I would do something called the muscle
draft where I would go and
disappear somewhere usually
far away where I could be
very alone and be very lonely and that
loneliness would inspire me to work hard
and fast and I would muscle out a draft,
which meant I would never go back.
It would,
it was all about just pounding through
it to get to the end as quick as possible
and it was like a two three day process
and you come that out with like um,
w if it ended up being
120 page screenplay,
you'd have an eight 79 80 page screenplay.
But in that muscle draft there
would be moments when you,
you know,
when you do enter that zone,
I don't know if you have a
term for it if you run into it,
but does that zone when you kind
of forget time, it's, you know,
I imagine athletes are doing it and rock
musicians seem to be doing it when they,
their eyes roll back in their head. But
as a writer, every while you get that,
where the way of time disappears and
something comes out on the page and that
scene is often something that ends up
staying all the way through to the end of
the process. When you are
muscling out that first draft,
is it in,
are you using screen reading software?
Is it just kind of brain
vomiting bullets on into a, a,
a word document? What does it look it's,
I'm trying to think. I mean, you know,
final draft has been around for a long
time now and it's a great software that
I've used. I don't, I don't know if
I'm Pi was written on it. It's hard to,
that was [inaudible] 97 so I can't,
I,
I doubt it probably I probably
was formatting stuff back then.
I don't really remember. Um, but
you know that that just helps you,
it helps you work quicker because you
know, instead of dealing with indentation,
you press tabs and shortcuts to get
through it quicker. I mean, you know,
screenwriting is very much like
sculpture in the sense that, you know,
if you start with a piece of clay,
you don't want to just focus on the hand.
You know, any artists that does
that will tell you, you know,
then the hand will be grossly
low, detailed and enlarged. The,
compared to the rest of the body,
you kind of just want to slowly start
cutting away at the clay to get closer and
closer to the final form,
you know,
but you don't want to get the sand
paper out till you're ready for that,
like level of detail work.
And so it's just about passes.
You keep going through it and once
you say, I'm going to start writing,
even if you get the page 30 and you
think, oh, page five need something,
you just make a note of it and then
Zap to the end before you ever go back.
So it's,
it's really like working at way,
working slowly away that big clay.
Do you no longer do the isolation
retreats? I do it less and less. I mean,
it's a funny story. I was just telling
my son, this was when I, when I wrote by,
uh, my friend actually who
does visual effects for me, um,
his parents had a little cabin up
outside of Woodstock and I was like, Hey,
can I go there for a few days and
pound out my muscle draft on Pi?
And he was like, yeah, sure.
And I went up there and that his parents
were intellectuals and just had books
and books and books. They were
academics. So there was tons of books.
And then I was looking,
you know, procrastinating,
looking through the books.
And of course the only book that
caught my attention was Carrie,
which I had never read.
So I proceeded to pound through
procrastinating by Reading Carrie.
It's scaring the living crap
out of myself. You know,
when you read king it's just like wow.
And then I really had it right quick
cause I had to get the hell out of this
cabin. So I think I wrote the first
draft of pie and like 18 hours. Wow.
But, but to talk about now,
um, it's funny this, this,
this new movie mother is very,
very different process. The,
the most different process than I've ever
done in probably more similar to where
I started.
I wrote the script and five days and
it was this kind of fever dream want to
happen. I had had the idea
two weeks before and you know,
it started off with this idea for this
allegory with a real kind of relationship
drama at the core,
but I didn't know how to structure it.
And then I had this kind of
breakthrough of what the structure is.
And I had a five day weekend without,
uh,
my son was with his mom and I was all
alone and I just sat in my kitchen.
I actually am and go up to the desk and
I just pounded it out in my kitchen,
in my underwear,
barely eating.
It was just like this fever that came
out of me and in five days and when I was
done with the script,
I showed it to my producers who didn't
know I was even working on something and
they were like, well, while the, I think
there's something here and it's weird.
I think I've always been
jealous of musicians. You know,
you hear the story where Bob Dylan wrote
a song in the afternoon and it became,
you know, the anthem for a
generation. But as filmmakers,
we really don't get to do that. It takes
us two to five years. I mean, you know,
Black Swan, the first meeting when
Natalie was 10 years before I shot it,
the wrestler was eight years.
The Fountain took me six years.
Noah was an idea for 20 years. You
know, it's a long time. I, I, but I,
I was like,
is it possible as a filmmaker to take
a single emotion and a feeling of,
and it's kind of what I was feeling right
in that moment and try to channel it
into a single track and into a movie.
And I think that's kind of,
it kind of captures a single emotion.
This film, even though it has other stuff,
it really was one color
that burst right through.
I want to talk about something maybe
related to fever dream. So the,
the idea of, or concept of madness, uh,
and uh, I want to say, I'm
certainly paraphrasing that,
that maybe you've said that by walking
the tightrope between sanity and insanity,
you can learn what sanity is
or something along those lines.
Do you have a fascination
with madness? I mean, if so,
or why do people have that perception?
I had an uncle who, um, was,
uh,
schizophrenia.
So I grew up around that and
I got to see it. I'm very,
very close and sort of saw his mindset
and also how it weighed on my family and
you know, the emotional ripples
from that were tremendous. Um,
and I then I also saw how society
treated people like that. And, um,
so it's,
uh,
it's something I've been very close
to and I've always thought about it.
And I remember reading, what
was it, the denial of death.
Do you ever read that book?
That's a good one for you. Um,
but they talk about the Liminal,
the line,
the thin line between the conscious
and the subliminal, I think,
how they were using between
genius and insanity.
And there were things that my
uncle would say that, I mean,
he was a highly functioning guy.
He worked at,
he worked as an engineer for New York
City for his entire life and you know,
had a pension and all that,
you know, may made it through,
but lived a very tough, tough life
because of the illness. But, um,
he would say things that were
just unbelievable. Brilliant.
Like I remember one time
my dad was talking to him about something,
you know, about how to do something.
I don't remember exactly the
details. And he said, well,
I can't really say this on radio.
Right?
And he said something like, yeah,
that's like, if you fuck a snake, again,
an elephant. And I remember hearing
it, I was whatever I was 12 or 13,
but that's kind of crazy metaphor and
kind of beautiful and it's so extreme,
you know, it was like the best
way of saying, yeah, right,
like you're selling me
the Brooklyn Bridge. So,
but he had many of those
that would just sort of like,
that's not proper English and,
but it kind of works, you know?
Do you, I've always had just
a, an absolute fascination
with that very thin line.
Uh,
when I was an Undergrad,
I was, I'm not a
mathematician. I, in fact,
part of the reason I went to Princeton
is because at the time at least did not
have a math requirement.
I was scared off of math by very a
belligerent teacher in 10th grade.
My, yeah, it was terrible. My
brother, in fact, same grade,
different teacher was steered in the
opposite direction and it's just finishing
a phd in social studies teachers can do.
But I was drawn to a few specifically
mathematicians at Princeton who were
really riding that razor's edge
and had multiple suicide attempts.
But we're also brilliant beyond all
description. Yeah. I personally,
and I in fact also have a
cousin whose schizophrenia,
which was relatively later onset and uh,
became effectively a different
person's still very smart. Um,
but have you ever worried that you
would bleed over that edge and you know,
luckily my Hubris doesn't go that
far, get that worry. I'm not,
I'm not the, I'm not crazy hypochondriac
and stuff, but yeah, sure. I've,
when I was a,
yeah,
I think when I was a teenager and
I read somewhere that like it,
like schizophrenia is onset can
happen in your 20s you know,
that that idea that when you're a fully
formed human being Suddenlink things can
change for you. That was a scary
idea. Will it happen for me? Um,
but you know, I, uh, you know, and I,
and I definitely think when it came to,
you know,
perhaps exploring, you
know, plant enhancements,
I was always a little terrified that I
might go too far in a certain direction.
But, um, you know, so, so it's always
been in the back of my head a little bit,
just cause, you know, a lot
of that stuff is genetic,
but I don't think it's really haunting
me. But I guess maybe a little bit, you,
you thought of the possibility
of the fear of it. Yeah. Well,
I almost off myself in college,
so I went through very,
very dark period,
uh,
that actually talked about really publicly
in a major way for the first time on
stage at Ted, which really shut the
room down. Well, no, good for you.
It's important, but, uh, that is always,
or has always been kind
of in the back of my mind.
And one of the things that
I got from as you put it,
plant enhancements or
psychedelic experience was
temporarily experiencing what
could only be,
I would have to be on some level
synonymous with extreme mental illness
definitely.
And having connection and developing
more empathy as a result of living in a
place like San Francisco where you're
just surrounded by people who are homeless
and mentally ill.
Uh,
so one of the topics I had down
to talk about was psychedelics,
which was suggested by someone we both
know who will remain nameless for now.
What I want to know,
yes there are only three,
but uh,
what role has that played in your life
or how do you think about it as fitting
into your life?
Well, I look, I think it's, I, I've,
I've researched it, read a lot about it.
I think it's very interesting. I
mean, you know, um, the story of, uh,
of deer that inside barrier
that eat mushrooms and fall
over and it doesn't seem
like there's any true shouldn't,
you know, survival of the fittest,
evolutionary positivity for a
deer to make itself that helpless.
So maybe there is something else going
on that some other medicine or something
else that this creature is getting out
of putting itself at risk was just a
fascinating idea.
And the fact that shamanism and reaching
alternative states has been just part
of our culture for a super long time and
then somehow got completely washed out
and I don't know, it turned into the
sacrament, maybe rock and roll music,
but we've really lost, um, you know,
anything that's sort of trying to
reach away from scientific reality is
clearly a loss. And,
um, and it seems like,
um, you know, the,
there's a lot of wisdom to come out of,
you know,
some exploration and in a
safe type of examination,
as long as very controlled environments,
it's as clearly tremendous benefit.
You know, that's happened, you know,
for society, you know, over eh,
that's recently been discovered and
is being rediscovered right now. Yeah.
Involved with some research at Johns
Hopkins and a few other places related to
use of cell Simon specifically in a
potentially addressing treatment resistant
depression among other things.
That's what's fascinating.
All that stuff that maps is doing with
PTSD and the fact that this department is
supporting it, you know, because
it seems to be working. You know,
I just saw a film that
came out of Israel that uh,
it is using MDM to sort of help people
deal with not just soldiers but people
deal with all different
types of emotional distress.
It's fascinating and it's
interesting and um, it's um,
clearly, you know, if the Defense
Department is sort of supporting it,
then there's probably some, you know,
it's probably pretty interesting to them.
I think it's also a really smart place
for research to start or one at least of
the subsets of the population that's very
smart to work with is returning vets.
Yeah. Specifically among other reasons
because it is a nonpartisan issue.
It's very hard to be like,
fuck the vets. Right.
Or like screw the terminal cancer
patients who want to decrease end of life
anxiety.
It's funny though because another thing
I'm involved with is I'm on the board of
directors for the Sierra Club and a big
part of what cr club is trying to do is
get vets into nature and we have all
these different programs that do that.
And in fact,
I actually went to the Arctic with two
vets and it was amazing for them to sort
of, you know, not just
to have that experience,
which is completely mind expansive
to see, you know, nature in a,
in a true to see true wilderness like
what's happening in the Arctic. But um,
I think to the, a lot of them, what
they expressed to me as they actually,
this is what they were fighting for was
the defendant this, you know, in their,
their spirits.
So they actually get to see the beauty
of America outside of the cities that
they're from.
Continue to talk for a little bit about
really old traditions because what we're
talking about, or at least some of these
traditions have existed for Millennia.
Fasting is another one. Yeah. Have
you done experiments with fasting?
A little bit. It's something I
definitely want to get more into.
I've been totally into the idea
for a long time. Of course.
Um, you know, I, I fast once a
year, uh, not that I'm religious,
but because I,
I liked the spiritual practice of
fastening once a day with my buddies.
And so I get together with my
friends and fast for that one day.
But a longterm fastening I think is
fascinating and I've heard great stories
about it, but I haven't, I
haven't actually had the,
it's amazing how little that goes on
and in our privileged lives and how,
you know, um, that's just a
very interesting practice.
What, what is interesting about it to
you? Because I tried to, for instance,
I tried to do and note to people
listening. I'm not a doctor,
I don't play one on the Internet,
so don't be stupid.
Talk to a qualified medical professional,
blah, blah, blah. But I've done a,
I tend to do at least three days
of consecutive fasting per month,
and then I'd go longer fasts a few times
per year. Wow. And you do just water?
I will make some allowances and I do
it differently at different times,
but what I will sometimes do is use
fasting as a way to kickstart ketosis.
So clicking over into
Ketosis, certainly, uh,
our friend Peter t knows a lot about that.
It was in Kansas for about
two and a half years straight,
but fascinating for a period of time.
Uh,
and what I will allow if I'm doing a
longer fast in particular is I will allow
myself non caloric drinks that are
unsweetened. So let's say black tea,
black coffee, right? Uh,
and Kit Kat bars and cake only
zero Calorie Kit Kat bars.
And I will also, particularly in
the beginning, allow myself, uh,
some exotic generates ketones. So
they're just supplemental ketones or fat,
like coconut oil to help
with the transition. That
was great, but besides that,
amazing Nick's than the pain is after
two, three days, right? It's supposed to,
she's off.
Yeah.
For most men,
women can sometimes take a little
longer to click over for most men,
about two to three days. Right. And then
you can, then you can click over. Um,
all right, well let's do it. I'm in w
what interests you about the fasting?
I mean, it once again, it's just the way,
it's clearly a way to explore
other spaces, you know? Um,
I mean I,
I immediately for me,
if I've got a difficult meeting where
I kind of have to be a jerk at because
something's not getting done correctly,
you know, if I skipped breakfast and uh,
do it close to when lunches,
you know, I, I get stuff done.
So I do it my own way. I do
miss, I do micro micro fasteners
to control my mood knowing
that, um, you know,
some of that anxiety and anger
will disappear as soon as I eat.
So it's sometimes a good thing to
sort of modem I motivate myself to,
to help with the work in certain ways.
So I do do my own mood enhancement.
I mean for a long time. Um, you know,
I was dating someone and you know, we used
to get at each other. And then finally,
um, someone turned me onto the word
hangry, which is the hungry Yang,
which I think is probably
pretty common now.
But at the time it was a pretty new word.
And that was,
it kind of changed my relationship and
kept the relationship going for three,
four years.
Cause we could actually identify why we
both became assholes for a little bit.
So clearly it's a major mood,
a blocker and changer and an
alternator and all that stuff.
So I think that's interesting.
And then, you know,
I've heard and read all about
the health benefits of it and,
and then of course there's
all the meditative elements
of it to control the mind
over the body and all, you know what,
David Blaine is always demonstrating, um,
clearly going to some series
extremes, but, you know,
I think there are lessons to be learned
and, and experiences to be, have,
have had during it.
This is sort of the nature
of my fragmented mind that
we're going to jump around
a lot. But you, you mentioned, uh,
difficult conversations or where
you have to be an asshole. Uh,
I had read about, well, very,
very much in passing you having a
conversation with Mickey Rourke before
filming. Uh, well these
version. Yeah. Well, no,
I actually don't have
a whole lot of content,
but roughly that you knew
it wasn't going to be easy,
that he had a lot of strong opinions.
So you had sort of a,
an honest upfront and conversation and
I would love to hear how you open a
conversation like that or plan for it.
You know, I look, um, you know,
Mickey at the time, you know,
had an awful reputation. Um, and I
think that's because, you know, he,
you know,
I think he in many ways he was a lot
of his worst enemy because he just,
you know, love, love to acting. But
he also loved boxing and you know,
and he had this fight and struggle between
them, which one was going to focus on.
And you know,
I think he was,
he really respected the box anyway.
Whatever happened with him, you know,
everyone was warning me about him.
Everyone.
But I love him and I loved his work.
Um, you know, before I knew him,
I just, I thought his work
was exceptional and I, it was,
I felt the crime on the acting arts that
he did not have more opportunities to
share himself with the world because
whenever he has shared himself,
it was unbelievable from barfly to angel
heart to all of the beautiful early
work he did.
And then it just sort of disappeared.
But I just wanted to be very
clear with him because I felt, um,
I just knew how challenging the film
we were about to do was going to be.
And I just, I, I find
that the longer I do this,
the more clear you can be upfront,
the better.
Because no matter what happens,
it always changes.
I think sometimes people don't really
hear what you're saying to them a lot
because they really want to do something.
So I try to be very,
very straightforward and clear because
I want to get all the PR as many of the
problems off the table because when we
do get to set time is really the biggest
enemy. Or, you know, pho,
because it's so short and,
and it happens so quickly that if you
start getting to stupid things that
weren't pre discussed,
it's a nightmare.
And so you have to be as completely
prepared and professional as you can when
you're spending whatever it is,
$20,000 a minute. Oh, you know,
whatever it may be that day,
you know, you want to, you know,
Mike Tyson tie money time
is what I'm talking about.
You want to be on top of your game.
So I just went in very clearly with
making it, I think, I think, well,
what it meant for Makey for it is like he,
he looked at me like medicine,
you know, he tasted really bad, but he
knew it was good for him. So, you know,
he just closed his eyes and opened his
mouth and swallowed to get it done. And,
and really to keep,
um,
because I think he knew deep in his
heart that what I was trying to do was,
you know, make a great film
with him and, uh, and then,
and then he rose to it and he brought
it and bring it. But, you know,
he talks about that meeting,
you know,
like the little skinny punk coming to
him in pointing his little stubby finger
in his face, which I love. I, it's funny,
I wish I was that tough
and that straight bode.
I'm sure I was more cordial and
polite to them because I was, um,
I know I was in awe of him
and excited to meet him. Um,
but I just wanted to be clear that like,
look, you know, if we're going to do this,
we were going to do this. Let's roll
up our sleeves and go for it. Um,
because it's just, for
me, filmmaking is so hard.
Um, I, I think for a lot of people there's
just so many challenges. It's like,
you know, literally every single film
I've done has been like, it's own IPO.
It's a, its own corporation. You
know, I start off with an idea.
I have attract talent and
money to come together. Um,
yes there's a formula,
but I generally are making things that
don't quite fit into the widget factory.
They're are a little weird and stuff,
so I don't think they fit in the region.
So we have to,
you know,
I have to convince people why it's
going to be a widget and then we have to
raise the money and hopefully,
you know, make it and get the,
get the investors' monies back. And you
know, I'm five or six, which isn't bad,
but you know, each time it's, it's a real,
it's a lot of work. So, um,
you wanna make the whole process of it
for all the artists working with you as
easy as possible. It's not really
where you want to put your fighting.
You want to do the fighting for the
world and the money and all that.
Let's say you're making a new film and
you're working with some one who you
respect,
just to depersonalize it a little bit.
All that you could give a real example.
Let's say like Mickey,
someone you really admire
who has a reputation for
being very strong willed and
you're going to have this conversation
and you're going to have this
conversation again. Yeah. How do you,
how do you open it? Like what is the,
what are some of the phrases that you
use to prevent it from blowing up or to,
uh, to try to allow it to go? Well,
of course. I mean, look, I mean,
I've never done a situation
where I'm asking someone, hey,
we're going to waterboard you for
three months. Yeah. I mean, um,
we're trying to do something that's
exciting and hopefully beautiful and you
know, you know, striving to make art.
So that's the underlining agreement.
So you're walking into that
conversation, Hey, I dig you, you dig me,
let's try to make this work.
But just to be clear,
these are some of the things that are
going to be going on that will probably
make you feel uncomfortable. And what
would be some examples of this? You know?
Well, I mean a lot of very clear
example would be, you know,
when working with women,
if there's things that,
or men with those things that
are sexual in nature, you know,
what's required nudity wise
and all that type of stuff.
And you have to talk about that beforehand
because of course it's very sensitive
material and you want everyone to be
comfortable and very clear on why you're
doing something. You know, anytime
you do like a love making scene,
what exactly is it going to be and why?
And I've never really,
I've never done a love making scene to
sort of make it sort of an erotic thing
for an audience. I, I always
try to tie it in narratively.
So I tell them very clearly
where the camera's going to be,
what we're going to do, how we're
going to run the set, stuff like that.
Same thing with violence.
Violence, I think is,
I'm just as important and the other way
of, you know what we're going to be,
how we're going to be
demonstrating violence, how are
we going to show it? I mean,
for me that's, that's a huge
pet peeve because I, I feel
in this country, you know,
sexuality and violence has flipped,
especially in the movies where you can
have as much violence as you want an a Pg,
PG 13 movie,
but you can't have an ounce of
sexuality and a Pg or PG 13 movie.
And that to me is, it's disgusting. I
don't have words to, to go beyond that.
The fact that we're training our kids to
fire guns at such a young age with nerf
guns and video games,
it's disgusting and disturbing while you
know any form of like saying there's a
beauty in human connection,
physical connection that no,
we can't talk about that.
And the fact that the NPA sort of
reinforces that and that's what I mean,
you know, I mean here I'll
go off, but like guns in ads,
I'll walk down the street.
We not, my kid was five, six years old
and my kids pointing I huge, crazy,
sexy looking machine guns on the
biggest movie stars in the world.
It's discussing the gun companies again,
free ads and you know,
yet you can't show someone kissing,
you know?
So there's a whole sort of bend with that.
I don't know how I got it
there. I got it. Sorry. Sorry.
I don't know how I get to
where I go half the time.
Want to talk a little bit
about the word Catharsis?
I recently saw a union film.
I really enjoyed the experience
and came away. I told you this for,
for a full day afterwards was in
this dream like state wonderful.
Which I savored and I had to,
I had a lot of questions and sometimes I,
I feel like we will actually Milan
Kundera I think said that, you know, the,
the stupidity of man is that he has
all the answers and the intelligence or
beauty of a novel is that it
has a question for everything.
Something like that.
Well,
that's interesting.
I'm paraphrasing and this is in his
book of laughter and forgetting,
but at one point I recall reading that
you didn't intend people to have to find
catharsis in your movies. You know, they,
they expect to have
happy endings and so on,
but that perhaps the catharsis
comes the day after seeing the film.
What do you want the experience of your
audience to be or what do you want them
to take away from any one of your films?
You could give a concrete example or just
in general something that drives you?
Well,
I guess I start off with,
you know,
the first rule of film making is
never to bore an audience. Um,
that to me is,
is the worst feeling and experience
when I'm watching a movie and my mind is
wandering and maybe looking at the
colors splattered across the screen.
I think you always want to engage
an audience, not just visually,
not just through sound,
but emotionally.
So I think that's rule one is just
to give people and engaging emotional
experience for two hours,
whatever your running time is.
And then I think,
uh,
on top of that you can hopefully layer
in some ideas so that when people leave
the theater, it's not like,
you know, 15 minutes later,
what did we watch?
You know,
I don't want to be the Mcdonald's of
movies where the rapper, you know,
it's just the wrapper is all that's left
over. I want people to be, you know,
thinking a bit about and talking about it.
For me,
one of my best life experiences was just
randomly I walked into a coffee shop
and it happened to be around the corner
from where pie was playing in la at the
new art.
And a dad came in with the,
his 18 year old daughter and two of
her friends and the four of them were
sitting there just talking about this
black and white movie that they had just
seen. And I just kind
of bs dropped, you know,
listening to him just thrilled that
there was a conversation and a debate and
what did that mean and what did that mean?
And you know,
for me that's always been the films
I love is, you know, yes, you know,
there are movies that you have a great
experience in and enjoy and it's just a
great pleasure to watch and
a great experience. But I
also liked the ones that,
you know, um, you know,
make you scratch your head and you think
about your talk and you debate because
uh, you know, you want to
kind of have an impact.
And I think in today's landscape a lot
of things are disposable and it's really,
really quick how disposable
they are because of how quick,
how much stuff we're being bombarded
with day after day after day.
Um,
it's nice to sorta hopefully
have something that reflects
back on it and thinks
about it. You mentioned
emotional thinking that said,
emotional connection or engagement.
What are the,
what are some of the ingredients
that helped to create that?
Because most films fail the eye
I think anyway. Yeah, I mean,
I mean it starts with the greatest,
I think the greatest invention of
the 20th century that's overlooked,
which is the close up and that,
that's the great thing about cinema is
the fact that you can stick a camera
right in the face of
Paul Newman, right? And,
and those beautiful blue eyes and
you can go right into his soul.
And then when you project it months
later to an audience or years later,
potentially centuries later,
you are anonymous and that audience,
yet you can feel the
empathy because in reality,
two people talking and hanging out.
How much eye contact do you make?
There's lots of other things going on
in this room that you're taking in that
act conditioner rattling my
guys mixing in the other room.
But the actual connection with another
human being where you are really looking
into their soul and not
thinking about yourself.
Cause the thing is when I look
at you and you look at me,
we're thinking a little bit about,
well now I'm making really a calm,
comfortable us looking at each other and
we will, we're going to be looking away.
But in a movie and via the close up
you can be unconscious and fully be in.
Paul Newman said, even though you
don't know exactly what he's thinking,
you can sort of study him and steel
and steel that thought. And that's,
that to me is the great
greatness of cinema. Um,
or one of the great things
about cinema. And so, um,
and that's where you get emotion.
You know,
and what happens is if you start
linking different emotions together,
hopefully you start to tell a story.
It store,
what the story does is it expands
the emotion. Just like a joke,
you know, set up, set up,
set up, pay off, you know,
that's the classic structure of a joke.
It's the same thing with drama or you're
setting up a character and building
character.
You give them a challenge and then you
see them go through that challenge and
pay off.
And then there's always the pitfall when
it all falls apart and then they rise
up. And at that hero's
journey, you know, is just so,
I don't know if it's genetic, I don't
know if it's part of the human condition.
I don't know if it's something that we,
we're taught very,
very young and our first
doctor Seuss books. Um,
but it's something that we all around
the planet and every language and every
culture can relate to. I mean, for
me, the power of storytelling happen.
I was,
um,
I graduated high school
early and backpacked around
Europe and the Middle East
and uh, I ended up in the,
the Gemma in Marrakesh.
I don't know if you've been there,
but it's a,
it's amazing square in the middle of
the suck, you know, whether I'll um,
where they have all the
shops and stuff and uh,
at nighttime they ha it's
filled with snake charmers
and food and all this stuff.
And there was one old guy leaning on a
cane and a beard telling a story and he
had a huge crowd around them and it was
all in Arabic and I didn't understand
the freaking word,
but I was mesmerized and I was like,
that's what I want to do.
I want to tell stories because
that little old trivial,
the old guy on a cane was transforming
himself into this 20 foot beast and I
didn't even understand the language.
And I was like, that's cool, you know,
to entertain a crowd with a point of view.
Where was that experience
relative to your time in Kenya?
But that was after Kenya.
I'm also on the board of directors for
an organization called the school for
Field Studies, which is a great
organization out of Salem, Massachusetts,
which basically trains
mostly college students, uh,
to go abroad and,
uh,
into sensitive environmental areas
and do environmental studies.
And when I was a, I
dunno, a young teenager,
I worked at New York City
aquarium in Coney island,
which was right next to my
neighborhood in Brooklyn. And the,
one of the big perks of that job
besides being at the aquarium,
was that if you wore
the aquarium tee shirt,
you got to go on the site clone roller
coaster over and over again. Um,
so we used to go 40, 50 times in a
row on the side, you know, and um,
but I picked up a book for the School
for field studies there and they,
it was just this little color
catalog and I was like, wow.
They sent kids to Kenya and I was
like, Ma, this is what I want to do,
dad. You know. And somehow they took
a few high school students and I was,
I was like in events, the
biology. So I had a little bit,
I was always good inside and
my dad was a science teacher,
so I was always pointed
in that direction a bit.
And so I got them to let
me go to Kenya where I, um,
I did what I study. I study thermo,
thermo regulate, no, I studied, um,
water strategies and ungulates the
next year I went to Alaska with them to
Prince William sound actually
with a big x on spill was,
but I was there two years before that,
which was fascinating because the research
we did there actually they use that
research after the, after the
spill to see what the impact was.
But in Alaska I studied
thermoregulation and harbor seals.
I just like to say these words cause
Sir fancy sounding ungulates now tell us
what fall into the class of ungulates are.
They're all animals that stand on their
hooves. Got It. So everything from cattle,
uh, you know, domesticated
cattle to Zebra Gazelle,
um, will be, yeah, there
were no deer elk. I,
there might've been some elk in some
type of elk there, but um, yeah,
so it's all that's true. Right. I
guess there would be Caribou in Alaska.
It was interesting. We basically
were there, we were on this,
we were on this ranch owned
by an Afrikaner who wanted to,
he did this thing called preservation for
profit was his idea where basically he
was like, look, during a
drought, all the cattle die.
But indigenous animals of course don't
die because they basically forage in the
morning when there's dew on the leaves
and then the mid afternoon they're in the
shade.
So Ba basically what we were there to
do is to prove his idea that indigenous
animals were better adapted to the
environment. Then domesticated animals,
which is completely obvious, but in
science you have to sort of prove it.
So we studied them morphologically,
which was biologically when they,
and then we also looked at them and
their behavior patterns during the day.
And I mean it was, it was fascinating
because basically we just use this,
you know,
I learned the scientific method and
we did real serious research and real
charting and real, you know, and it,
the next year was Alaska when
I went to Prince William Sound.
And the beauty of that was the textbook.
The only textbook we had was origin sbcs.
And each,
every two days we had a read
another chapter of origin
of species and discuss it.
And over the six, seven weeks I was
out in the bush. That was the whole,
the whole class.
I had read that your time,
as soon as acting as a field biologist
are doing field biology in Kenya changed
how you looked at the world. Now I
don't want to put words in your mouth,
so I don't know if that's accurate
or not, but if that is true, yeah.
How did it change how
you looked at things?
Everything changes your life all the time.
Right?
But back at that age when you're 16 and
you're a Brooklyn kid from New York City
who's basically, you know, you know,
concrete jungle flee and
you've suddenly in, you know,
the Savanna of Kenya,
of course it's gonna Change Your Life.
So it's a little bit of an
overstatement I think. But um,
I mean every day was mind blowing.
I, as an embarrassing moment,
I was 16 so you have to forgive me.
I got off the plane and I was riding
with the professors to the thing.
I was like, Oh, when are we
gonna See Tigers? They're like,
there aren't any tigers in
Africa. They're in Asia. Oh,
that's what I meant. So I, you know, a kid
from Brooklyn, no idea what was going on.
So I mean,
every day it was just every day literally
was something I had never seen before.
And now in Alaska,
and you know,
this is a pre Google pre crazy media age,
you know,
still only 11 channels on the station
at the couple of people had cable,
but early days of civilization.
And um,
I remember we were kayaking.
It was an amazing trip.
It was like five weeks in kayaks
out in Prince William Sound,
one of the most untouched places on the
planet at that point until Exxon showed
up.
And we can,
we were going to this glacier
and I had never seen a glacier.
Now everyone's seen a glacier
at this point because of that,
the calving ice and what's
happening to the glaciers.
But the idea of blue ice for a kid
from Brooklyn and they're like this
[inaudible] glacier. When the first time
I saw it, it was like two miles long,
you know, half a mile
tall. I mean, I just,
with huge chunks of ice falling and
you'd see the chunks fall off and then a
minute later you'd hear the sound because
of the distance, like at a ballpark.
And then these huge waves from that start
coming at you and you're in a kayak.
So you really close to water.
And on those waves are icebergs with
seals hauled out regulating their
temperature on it, going
up and down. I mean,
just like who needs psychedelics?
You've been called controversial. I don't
know if you view yourself that way. Um,
but I'd love to talk a little bit about
how to respond to public perception and
criticism. Another mutual
friend of ours, Rick Ruben,
fantastic guy, uh, incredible
music producer, uh,
among other greatest. Yeah, he is. He
said on this podcast, he said, the best,
the best art, I'm paraphrasing, but
the best art divides the audience.
And so I think it was, uh, help me
out here. I think it was variety.
The day after you got a 30
minute standing ovation,
said you should quit filmmaking
and go therapy instead. And, uh,
you've had as anybody
who's in the public arena,
uh, has, uh, a fair amount of say,
criticism of various types.
Yeah.
What would your advice be to a
filmmaker you think is very promising?
Who's doing something that is not,
that doesn't fit cleanly in
the widget factory? Yeah.
They're probably gonna catch fire,
but they haven't had the experience.
What would you say to a person that's
an easy answer? Keep going. You know,
that's what you want. I mean, I, when
I meet, uh, when I teach are like my,
both my parents were teachers and so I,
I, it's in the blood and I love teaching.
You know,
the thing I try to instill in students
is like the only thing you have to offer
as you, you know, your individual
stories, your individual perception,
your individual humanity,
and figuring out a way to
communicate that humanity to the,
to humanity at large. I mean, that's
the beauty of cinema, once again,
that you can have a six year old Iranian
girl, our 90 year old British gentlemen,
and you can have an equal emotional
experience if the filmmaker does their job
right to it. So like for me it would be,
you know, a ballerina and a wrestler,
hopefully. Can I make you feel and
their blood in their pain. That's,
that's the goal. Um,
because that's, you know,
that that's one of the
great things cinema does,
is to bring us into other human
experiences. So if you're,
if it's truthful to who you are and you're
concerned about how people are going
to react to it,
you know,
stick up your middle finger and charge
straight into that fire, you have to, um,
if you're trying to be a provocateur,
just to be a provocateur, you know,
go f yourself. You know, that to me is,
that's the bad stuff is
like when it's not real. Um,
so for me it's not, it's
never like, oh shit, how do
I, you know, mess around with,
that's not why I make movies at all.
I,
I'm just juiced about these
ideas. And um, they had,
they have nothing about
being confrontational. But
even when I do a film, like,
you know, you know, the fountains
been called a love poem to death.
I piss people off even though it's just
really gentle move romantic movie about
a guy coming to terms with dying.
I guess that's just not a very commercial
idea in the west. But you know, I,
I thought it was at the time
and I was like, you know,
dancing around for five years
telling studios I was going to it,
that people would be interested in the
movie. And because I really believed it,
I wasn't, I'm not interested, you know,
I happened to be a filmmaker who
wants to talk to audiences. I love it.
I love when they respond.
Unfortunately I haven't done a
comedy or something that's easy,
quite yet easier to connect with an
audience on, easier to make by any means.
But I just mean,
you know when you're going to,
when you're aiming the please annoyance,
it's a lot easier to make it then when
you're just making something that you
feel inside.
And for me it's not a conscious thing.
It's purely from my gut. That's the core
for me. It comes from my stomach always.
It's not the heart, it's mostly
where it might be somewhere between,
I don't know what's right
here, solar plexus. It's right
beneath the solar plexus.
It's kind of this stomach, I guess
like your large intestine. Oh Great.
Let's play this die there.
It's that, that area,
when I feel when I'm writing and
it's like coming out of there,
I know it's like some type
of Chana g from there. Si.
Do you pay a lot of attention?
Does your kinesthetic response to
what you're doing when you're writing?
I mean you, it's that unconscious state
where you're not feeling body. That's the,
that's the state to get into where
just coming of you, you know.
And, and that it's not by,
by no means is that often.
You know, I, I believe there
are writers out there. Um,
I was very, I know some real
writers and I think they are,
I get into that state a lot
easier and I'm not a real writer,
but sometimes I have ideas and that I
want to get out and express and so I,
I tried to do it.
Why do you say you're not a real writer?
People who would argue that
you have writing credits? I
don't know. I mean I just,
I guess I, I'm in awe of, I have,
I have some friends that really,
right. And I see the way they can put
words together. I don't, you know,
look the reality, I'm being more truthful
with Ferris then I've been with him,
probably anyone.
The reality is I was a public
school kid from Brooklyn and I,
they never really taught me how to write.
And when I got to college,
I went into the creative writing class
and I almost flunked out of it because I
really did not know how to write an essay.
I didn't even, I, I to this day, my,
my son,
my 11 year old son knows more about
pronouns and nouns and sentence structure.
I just never learned grammar. It was
never talked to me and, and then,
and it was a shame. I just
never, I never did the Romeo,
so I probably have some type of security
about that cause I don't think I could
write that. I can write dialogue
because I have an ear and, and I,
and I do have some ideas that I can try
to sketch out, but I don't really, um,
you know,
I guess I'm scared of,
I'm scared you're going to
give me an essay to write
challenging one. I'm going, going
to be the last person he did.
He just say it right. My, my, uh,
writing my senior thesis in college,
which is mandatory and it constitutes a
huge part of your departmental grade for
the entire time that you were at school.
Yeah,
traumatize me so much that I
pledged to myself when I graduated.
I would never write anything
longer than an email ever again.
Clearly did not work out. Uh, it worked
out, but it didn't work out as planned.
I guess thesis on my thesis was on the
phonetic and semantic acquisition of
Chinese characters in
the Japanese language.
It's called [inaudible] by
native English speakers.
So how do native English speakers most
effectively acquire both the meaning and
pronunciation of Chinese
characters? Um, unbelievable. Yeah.
In retrospect,
it doesn't seem like someone who's afraid
of writing would write something like
that. That's pretty, you know, I had,
I had a lot of my true interests were
buried in some of these early writing
projects or even scientific assignments
that I then felt were trivial or not
serious for some reason. And now I'm
coming back to them 20 years later.
I'm amazing.
I mean,
I remember I took a neuroscience
class initially the plan was to be a
neuroscience major.
Actually.
It was a psychology major focusing on
neuroscience for a host of reasons.
Move to the language,
namely principally,
I couldn't do the animal testing that
was required to be part of the lab.
I want it to be part of.
Yeah, I mean I, I will say,
I mean I understand the
sensitivity of the subject.
I do think some studies are very difficult
to do or impossible to do without
certain animal modeling.
But let me just say that for instance,
one of the studies, I've been deep
into this. No, I know you. I know you.
I don't want to own up for
environmental reasons. Just
Oh, for sure. I have a, well,
we'll talk about it later. No, we can,
yeah, we can definitely talk about the,
but where I became,
I was really fascinated by
rem sleep and some of the sea,
the physiological
similarities to state states.
It can be induced with hallucinogens.
Oh Wow.
And so this was probably my sophomore
year in college that I was really
fascinated by this.
And it only took 20 years,
25 years to come back to it full circle.
Did you ever try to stay
awake for a long time?
I stayed awake and this
is not advisable at all.
I wanted to see what the
disclaimers, you know, because the I,
every once in a while I'll get an email
from somebody's cousin [inaudible] he
said, and he gave himself a
headache. And I'm like, yeah,
you got to use your common sense people.
But I stayed away for six days. Oh Wow.
I wanted to see what would happen because
I had read these reports of people
having all sorts of odd phenomenon crop
up when you stay awake for that period
of time. And uh, so I used a stimulants,
nothing illegal,
but it was very good at concocting putting
together these cocktails for myself
and stayed awake for five and a half,
six days.
I stopped because I was walking on campus.
I remember very clearly
where I was. I was, I was,
you would make it [inaudible] Hagen
and there were goblins everywhere.
No,
I fell asleep while I was walking and
woke up about a block later and I had
crossed two or three. Oh Wow.
And I was like, you know what,
this is no longer a good idea.
But you,
have you stayed awake for a really
long period of time? No, I had a,
there was a test when I was in Undergrad
and my roommate did it where he
basically was to stay awake
and he just became cruel.
And I remember him telling me like
they, they were like, oh, he's like,
I'm going to go to sleep to like,
don't go to sleep.
So he took a deck of cards and start
throwing cards around the room and made
everyone run around and pick them up.
Otherwise he would go to sleep.
So he started doing like really
messing with the aids and the,
and the Grad students that were
doing the studies on him. Yeah.
But of course the overnight or, and
those are important. Not just, you know,
when you're in college and stuff,
but I haven't, I'm glad you,
you are out there exploring
it for us. Yeah. I don't, the,
the conclusion is don't do that.
Inclusion is don't do that.
And if you remove sleep and food from
people, they get really, really grumpy.
It turns out,
uh,
this is a quote from New York magazine.
This may have been from a while ago, uh,
on, I don't think it's that old actually.
So I think when I was starting out as
a filmmaker, I had tremendous focus,
but I don't think I robbed
myself of too much life.
I'm still friends with the guys
who grew up with a nursery school.
I have a great relationship.
My family,
I'm definitely attracted
to balance to symmetry.
I'm definitely an order personality,
but I'm a lot less ordered than I was.
God Damn,
I said some stupid shit.
So you can definitely deny you can
correct it and set the record straight.
But this is of incredible interest to me
because many people who would aspire to
be creative or who self describe as
creative burn themselves out or they
sacrifice family relationships
by being singularly focused.
And sometimes they're proud of it.
Sometimes they regret it. But this is,
this is something that
I don't hear very often.
So I was wondering if you could just
elaborate on that because how do you have,
how do you have the tremendous
focus required to do what
you've done while still
having that balance and symmetry?
I mean, it is a balancing
act and you know, uh,
but I think all the
time you put into life,
you know,
and to family and to friends and
into activities outside of the work,
you know,
back to our procrastinate.
Not to say what your
family is procrastination,
but bringing in those other experiences
into your life is what makes you be able
to relate to people and to communicate.
And at least for filmmaking,
that's a major part is you know,
going to a diner with friends and seeing
an argument between some strangers over
there ends up in a
movie. For me, you know,
living life and seeing stuff and doing
all different types of experiences
through this planet is important to be
a storyteller because it's all about the
stories.
I mean I think the first three,
four films of my career and definitely
all my short films before that all came
out of very personal
experiences of my life. And,
and the problem is if you keep working
nonstop and you're originating your
material, I think it's different
if you're more of a journey,
men who's going along and then just
taking your craft and bringing it to life,
bringing a great script to life.
Cause I think at the,
you mean by that as a journeyman,
something that's not a personal story.
By nature.
I mean,
I think every stories personal or you
can find a personal way because anytime
you portray a character on screen,
you should sort of infuse them
with real emotions and stuff. So,
and to do that you have to
feel it yourself. But, um,
if you're drawing on your own life and
your own stories and you're somehow more
autobiographical somehow,
even through metaphor,
because I think all my films are
not about, I'm not a ballerina yet.
You know, there's a lot of Natalie
in me. I mean that character,
Nina and me, not Natalie, but Nina,
the character, I'm not a wrestler,
but Randy the Ram I,
I'm pretty connected to and I understand
why he makes every decision and some of
those stories in there I can relate to or,
or drawn from my own life.
So I think,
you know,
if it's an assignment
where you don't really,
you just showing up as a director
and you're there to, you know,
make all the departments work
together and make the actors do it.
I think it's the, it, it becomes,
it becomes more of a craft then,
not to say that it's not an art,
but I think if you're trying to create
your own stories that are coming out of
life, you have to actually live
life to do it, you know? Right.
Otherwise you're just
getting your stories.
I don't know where you
could get your stories from.
I guess you could make things
about being an obsessive film,
which is kind of like, you know, one
of my favorite filmmakers, Fellini,
started making films about
directors, making films, you know,
I mean eventually went
off until the things,
but for a while that's what he worked on.
And so I think you,
you have to balance in this, in this art
form. It's, it's very different, I think,
uh,
in different forms because all the forms
can be expressed in different ways.
So I, I can't really speak for that,
but, but storytelling, you need stories.
Realize if something has told at
one point, which helped me at least,
which was a friend of mine, a writer,
I think it was, it might've been,
it was either. Debbie Millman, I want to
say, or Maria Popova. And they said, uh,
if art imitates life,
you have to have a life.
Right?
And I guess my followup question is when
you are really immersed in a project,
yeah.
And maybe maybe now with family and so on,
it's different than in the early days,
but
my experience and part of the risk I
have when I go into a project is that it
tends to crowd out other things,
right?
You schedule say time with friends and
family so that they don't get displaced.
How do you ensure that that happens or
you just programmed in such a way that
it's natural? It's not a bad life
as a filmmaker because basically,
at least the way my,
my schedule is, I do a,
a film every two, three years.
So in that two, three years,
there'll be like a 50 60 day Ron,
which will be completely selfish and
completely committed and dedicated to the
film where I'm working 1820
hour days over and over again.
Insane amount of time.
And you know,
you get one day off on the weekend and
then the next day you probably prepping.
Um, although I'm able now to almost get
two days off because I've been doing it
enough that I kind of have more skills
but I can go in so can get a weekend off
sometimes. But where I can
spend with family and friends,
not that I could go out
and party and have a beer,
I mean it's gotta be very mellow and
most of the time I'll just want to watch
game of Thrones. But that's
a huge marathon. That only
happens once every two,
three years. And then you get into editing
and it's basically a nine to five job.
You know,
there's always things coming up,
but it's a much slower pace and
that could be a 40 week process.
Then you get to selling the film,
which is kind of a two,
three week kind of marathon of travel.
But it's kind of fun cause that's where
a lot of stories come from because you
see all these different cultures and
you just see a lot of crazy shit.
So it's not that bad. And then,
and then I get into development.
And when I'm in development for
the next project, it's, once again,
I can really shape that around,
um, my son's schedule and, and,
and I can have time to see my friends
and have experiences and travel and stuff
like that. Because when you're developing,
it's all virtual, virtual in your head,
not quite in a computer, but it's, it's
all in your imagination for a while.
And all you need is a notepad and
a pen and you can be anywhere.
Are there any particular resources,
and I'm sure this is a question you've
had a lot, so I apologize in advance,
but I haven't heard the answer.
So to aspiring filmmakers,
uh, let's just assume intelligent, driven,
organized, so big assumption, but let's
just assume they check those three boxes.
Sure.
Are there any particular books
or resources or approaches
that you would suggest
they take?
Assuming that they're,
they want to put together some type of
narrative storytelling about doing a
document. I always push the writer's
journey by Christopher Vogler.
It's very good, but it's only for people
who are writing screenplays. So, but he,
but he's great.
He basically took Joseph Campbell's work
and turned it into screenplay language
and he did a really good at job at it
and we're totally part of his cult. Uh,
cause we,
I believe in that hero's journey.
And not to say that's
the end all to end all.
And there are other ways to approach it.
But it's a very,
very interesting structure that can
really lead to big breakthroughs.
When you're struggling,
you can look at the different
archetypes that there are and,
and often you find yourself
falling into it. And, and you know,
it's funny like requiem for a
dream. When I was working on it, I,
it was before I read Vogler, but
now that I look back, I, I still,
I was doing stuff similar where I was
charting out where their emotion was,
the characters.
And what was interesting is that the
graph was actually upside down when
something good was supposed to happen,
something bad was happening.
And I was looking at it one day
I flipped it over and I said, oh,
they're actually the bad guys. All my
characters. The good guy is addiction.
And this is actually a hero's journey of
addiction, overcoming the human spirit.
That's when I finally understood what
the movie was about and charting it and
using hero's journey, how I was able
to figure out that, that id out,
that this invisible monster was a,
of this craving was actually the hero
of the film. But that's great. I mean,
and then the other thing back on what
we talked about is, you know, tell,
tell your story.
Don't try to figure out what
people want because the reality is,
you know, and I kind of learned this when
I, when I was coming out of film school,
I went to support my friend Scott Silver,
who's a big screenwriter.
Now we have made a directed a film that
was at Sundance and it was the year that,
uh, welcomed the doll house was there
and a bunch of other indeed jams.
And I remember watching these films go,
these are such specific,
unique movies,
but they're done exquisitely well.
And what Sundance allowed me to believe
in what independent film has allowed so
many dreamers to believe
is that if you make a film,
well no matter how personal it is,
if it's truthful,
you'll find an audience.
So not, not to invoke the
name of, of Rick again,
but I was having a conversation with,
with rec recently in a barrel sauna
that as the exact replica of his barrel
sauna
and that we were talking about this
deadline that I continually, uh,
I'm actually working hard on the book,
but I, I spent a lot of time talking,
I spent a lot of time talking about how
hard I'm working on the book. And uh,
I was asking him some questions about
working with musicians and whether he
knows if something has hit the mark or
not. And uh, I'm going to paraphrase here,
but he said effectively great is
always better than now. And Oh,
that's interesting. And, and in the
way I interpreted that was, you know,
there's always a good time for great.
There's never a good time for mediocre.
So if you feel like you were rushed
to hit some kind of deadline,
obviously are realities of production and
so on. Don't get me wrong, but uh, yeah,
rush. You can't rush that. That's,
you know, I mean Rick's filled wisdom.
Yeah. And it always comes out
so interesting. Um, but yeah,
I get that. It's, you can't force it.
The threat I want to tease a little
bit is something you mentioned earlier,
which is a say the argument between the
strangers that in the diner that then
makes it into your movie.
Right.
Could you tell us or tell me since
I'm just sitting right here, uh,
your,
your history with the game of go,
I got into it a lot when I was doing pie,
I needed a game for the two guys to be
playing so that they had some reason that
they were meeting so that Max
and his mentor could meet.
And I just thought playing chess was just,
we've seen it so much and it's cliche
and mathematicians playing chess was just
not quite interesting enough.
And at that point 97 go was still very
much a fringe game, sort of is still.
And um, but I think it was
much more fringe then and
we used to go a lot to the,
the New York go, um, meetings,
which were like 18 very intellectual
people and very book line departments at
different houses each week playing go.
So it was a great cast of characters,
just a fight. And they, you know,
the best thing about go
character go characters are
the ones that have said that
blow off chess as like a
full scale. You know, they,
they so looked down on chess and it's
just such a chip on their shoulder that
they've, they've graduated
to go. But that, you know,
and the thing that's fascinating that
I've been hearing a lot of people,
I think actually Rick was talking to me
about it. That's where I heard it was,
well he's the one I suggested I ask you.
Oh, there you go. But the documentary,
which I haven't seen yet,
he told me those are some
documentary about what it meant.
This computer finally
beating these go masters.
And he was telling them about a
scene where after the first move,
the go master gets up and
walks away because basically,
I guess the point was that it's such a
radical way to change of how the game is
played,
how this computer is playing it,
that it's actually affecting now how
humans play each other when that's,
that's a line about AI that is
interesting where, you know,
it actually changes the way we act with
each other after thousands of years of
playing a game a certain way.
Suddenly this idea comes that is a moment
of genius that changes the way we look
at the board. That was interesting
idea. And the, is that from a dot?
That's from a document. I believe
so. But you have to ask Rick
fascinate me and I was, I've been
thinking about it for 4 cents. See that?
And yeah, I don't want to take us
totally off the rails, but I play go.
I have a go board at my house.
I know. Not Good. Yeah. Uh,
I tend to play a hybrid version of
connect for fellow connect five.
I doubled my brother and I love to play,
we just call it connect five or something
like that where we use a goal board
and it seems really childish.
But my brothers, I mean he's,
he's a statistics phd, very
good chess player. Oh Wow.
And these games can actually
last a really, really low.
It's just basically getting five in a
row and you could place him anywhere on
the board. It sounds great. It's
a great, and it can, it can take,
you don't flip on tiles or anything,
it's just about blocking jumps.
You leave them there so
you're not capturing, well,
you are capturing territory,
but the rules are completely
different from real go. Yeah. My,
my son came home from math class with
fat on paper and we played it for a while
and I was like, wow, this
was complicated gang.
Super complicated and go is so
fascinating on many, many levels.
One of which is you can
feel like you're winning.
And then effectively if your,
if your pattern recognition is off in
a handful of moves, completely loose.
I mean, it's, it, the tide
can turn a lot faster. Uh,
I shouldn't say this with any degree of
expert credibility because I know people
like Josh Waitzkin are actually good
at chess. I'm not, but, uh, uh, the,
the game I got really into, uh, in Japan.
So my first trip abroad
was a year in Japan as an exchange
student at a Japanese school,
lived with a Japanese family.
And I listened to the session
you did with the knife maker. Oh,
Spam Murray Carter Murray is amazing.
So I want to get something of his knives
are incredibly shit. There's so good. Uh,
the Boutiquey line, oh,
his stuff is amazing.
It's the game I got
into was called a Shogi.
So shogi Japanese chess. Oh
Wow. And what makes shopping?
He's chest different and there are
ways you can play western chest this,
this way,
but you're able to reuse the captured
pieces and just drop them on the board at
different places. And then also,
not only do ponds get promoted,
there are multiple pieces that turned
into completely different pieces. Sorry.
Cool. When they get supposed to
serve a lot of chess. Yeah. Yeah.
It's really a cool game. And so there's,
um, I used to buy these books in Japan,
so she'll get somebody Shogi is,
uh,
basically books that allow you
to think of a really slow APP.
It's a book where you,
you try to figure out the three or four
moves in a given position necessary to
win the game. And then there's an answer
key. And so I would on the subway,
she had a lot of time on the
subway in Tokyo. At least I did.
I would either read comic books or I
would look at these some issue or I would
read judo textbooks. Um, but
I'm, I'm getting judo. Yeah.
Um, as an aside, yeah,
it's funny, the one eye, it was
very upsetting when they got, um,
Wifi on the New York City subway
because now I have to work hard.
But like my rule is never
take out your phone.
Not because I'm worried about
getting stolen or anything,
but just because that's the chance
to watch people for me. And um,
so you don't want to get lost in your
device at that point. That's a great time.
And the, and the rule in
New York is great. You know,
basically you can stare at anyone you
want. If they make eye contact with you,
you can never look at them again,
but you're allowed to look as long as
they don't look at you. And that's that.
People come to New York. I
said, that's the real, you can,
you can watch and check each other out.
But if they need realize you're
being checked out. Stop. So I,
I find it fascinating
and I imagine, uh, yeah,
the subways in Japan must be insane.
It's just, once again, you know,
which shocked me that,
I mean there's so many things that are
so alien about Japan for someone who
hasn't been exposed to Japan specifically,
even in East Asia.
And I've spent time in China,
I've gone to school there,
I've spent time in Taiwan and spent
time in Japan, Japan, and within Japan.
Tokyo is just a particularly a
particular brand of weird. Yeah.
And so you get on the subway
and I remember a couple
of things really striking
me. Some 15 everything's backwards, right?
We're driving on the
opposite side of the street,
like we have to take a shower
before we get into the bath.
I'm like all these rules that seem
very Alison wonderland, topsy turvy.
And then I sit down on the
subway and you'll see, you know,
the salary men Saturday mom who are on
their way to work these worker bees and
their reading comic books with
the most explicit porn imaginable.
And they're completely
nonchalant about it. Yeah, I
mean, Tentacle Porn, who knows?
And then the, uh, the other
hilarious phenomenon I bumped into,
which I'd really didn't expect.
So you hear about in Japan,
perverts on the subways and they're
definitely perverts on the subways and
they're called Chicago. So if
you're like, she can't, you got to,
that means a pervert per, per. Oh, really?
And so if like some guys trying
to fondle some girl's ass,
like you'll hit a key or Chicong and
then, you know, there's big kerfuffle.
What they don't tell you is that, uh,
I remember one day I was in my street
Conan kerfuffle in one sentence,
just so you know,
might be the first time, uh, the
singularity is near. And, uh,
I was in my school uniform 15
clearly a high school student, right.
Have my Judy uniform over my shoulder.
It's wrapped up and I'm standing
up as packed subway and I fear,
I feel someone groping my ass. Oh Wow.
And I'm like, what is going on here?
I can't turn around because it's so
crowded and eventually I'm able to turn
around and what do I see?
Not what I expect.
I see two really old women
with like half of their teeth,
w captain gold chuckling to themselves
because they'd been grabbing my ass.
And these women are called [inaudible]
young [inaudible] young is from old
battalion,
which it's a long story,
but it refers to like older Japanese
women who just don't give a fuck anymore.
And so, yeah, it was a real
cold night. My favorite,
you know, when I went to Japan for the
first time, which was with pie, you know,
I was, I was a big, huge
fan of, um, I had all,
I dreamt for so long and I go to Tokyo.
Um, and I was like, you know, I Kinda,
I want kind of want to make a
statement here. I kinda, you know,
I want to be remembered, you know,
I'm coming with this a little film,
what can I do?
So I had dyed my hair purple and I came
and I do an interview is the whole time
with big bright purple hair
and no one mentions it.
And I get to my last interview and it's
kind of a young hip guy who's like a pop
star in Japan and we become buddies
and I'm like, man, you know,
like I've made my head purple, but no
one's commented on it. And he goes, yeah,
come to the window. And we look outside
and it's a major intersection. Says,
who has purple hair out there?
All the old ladies,
hi, they are here. And I'm like, oh,
that's totally true. Hundred
percent accurate. Oh my God,
I don't even pieces together.
That's true. I'm having flashbacks.
I think the old ladies are grabbing
that and it's like, you know,
in requiem for a dream, they dyed
their hair red and then it's purple.
So probably funny.
So speaking of Tentacle Porn,
uh, this is, that's about as
graceful segway as that can make,
and we don't have to talk about
this if you don't want to,
but this is one of the bullets that was
recommended for me to talk to you about.
And I should preface this by saying,
in my second book for our body,
there are two chapters on female orgasm,
two on various aspects of male sexuality.
So I'm not shy about talking about this,
but recently I'm on the Howard stern show,
suddenly are in the Howard stern
show restricting ejaculation.
I don't have any context for this,
but I was told to ask you about
restricting ejaculation. Wow.
Where'd you get that from?
My sources cannot be made.
Uh, but is that something
that you can tell us about?
Um, I'm not sure what you're
referencing. Oh, I think, oh,
there we go. It's coming back to
me. Oh, W it was funny. I had,
I had a, um, well there's in,
in a requiem for a dream that is something
in the background called month of
fury. Um, which was, I guess
it was early self-help. Um,
I had, uh, when I, wow,
this is going way back and actually kind
of flows a little bit into probably why,
um,
we're,
we're a growing friendship has
happening here because, uh,
similar roots in a certain way. But when
I, my first, when I was in film school,
and then there's another great thing
for young film students to know is like,
there's usually the first screenplay
you write that we'll never get made.
And believe me, that happens. And
at a certain point you have to be,
you take the bold step to abandon it,
you know,
because there's a learning process.
And that first script,
and I worked on a script that was
set in Coney island and I had a guy,
really talented kid I grew up with who
probably if you went to Wall Street would
be a, you know, a hundred
millionaire type of guy.
But he ended up getting involved in
this kind of culty organization that are
those guys who go around and sell roses
and little toys around the streets
wearing ties.
I don't know if you ever see them.
There are a lot on the
west coast and they,
they're basically kind of pyramid schemes
where you basically open up an office
and you hire like 10 20 year old kids
and they go and they hustle for you and
then you buy it from a guy above you.
And then if you get a few,
you slowly move up this type of thing.
And they have these huge conventions in
Vegas with where they all come together
and they have all these chants where
they choose each other up and get all
excited. And I, I, when I
was in film school, he was
in the, uh, west coast area.
And so I just sort of studied it
and hung out with them. Once again,
here's another play, hang out with a
friend but also kind of get stories.
So I developed this whole
kind of characters and world
for this movie about this.
And eventually I didn't make that film,
but I was able to take that character and,
and when I had to bring a Hubert
Selby Jr is requiem for a dream alive,
Sour Goldfarb.
The old lady watched a lot of TV,
but we couldn't afford the
TV to put TV on the channel.
So I decided to make my own TV show and
create and create kind of a Tony Robbins
ask because Tony was just
starting and it was, he,
he didn't sort of evolve into
the kind of figure he is now.
At the time he was sort of a tele van. No
one really knew what it was. And it was,
it was odd.
So I kind of create my own sort of of
that and had this guy on TV and I had to
give him a philosophy.
So I had an act,
a friend who was also a boxer and he
had this thing called Mama Fury Eddie.
The harp is his name.
And it was three rules,
which are actually three great
rules. It was 30 days. Uh,
no refined sugar,
30 days,
no red meat and 30 days, no. Our, yes,
now those all together. Yeah. You do
all three, four a month for 30 days.
And it was actually a very
interesting, you know, so,
so he preached it to me cause he would
do it before he would box or one more.
You died? No refined sugar, no
refined sugar. So that's everything.
Like toothpaste anywhere where
there could be sugar, you know,
no red meat and then no orgasm.
So in the movie requiem for a dream,
the third one is not actually pitched it
because I just thought it would be good
as a little secret. Now I'm sort of giving
it away, although it's come out of it.
Uh, it's, it's actually in there.
It's actually in their bit.
It's an Easter egg that's
hidden in the film somewhere.
It was funny because when I'm, you
know, when we started working on it,
I suggested it to the actors that they
should go on a month of fury before we
make the movie.
Just to understand what it is to withdraw,
which is a big part of the movie creek.
Cause it's hard if you're not a
drug addict or a smoker, you know,
to actually stop to something for 30 days
to fast as you talked about too. It's,
it's really tricky.
And here with three things that
were seemingly not hard to do.
And it was funny to, you know, run,
see my actors that they 24 and
25 wind to kill me, I don't know.
And it's the month I have
another friend of mine,
well my best buddy who actually on
day 29 ended up proposing to a woman,
which I was like,
you never propose on day 29,
what are you out of your freaking mind,
the month of fury,
fury. So if I ever did a self
help, that would be, you know, hey,
if you want to cowrite and
start a movement, I know
you, I know you've got down,
you heard here first folks,
I could, I could get,
I think quite a few people to
participate in the muck theory,
actually very effective.
I'd love to ask quite a few
questions about the new film. Uh,
but the first is related
to the writing of the film.
So when you are writing a film
like mother and there are many,
and I don't want to give anything away,
but many visual components,
how do you write that type of material?
Being the writer and then the director.
I can sort of,
um, not worry about that that much, but
there are two different steps. I think.
First you're writing and you're following
along the emotional truth of the
characters and following scene by scene,
what's going on and
watching the story unfold.
And then there's the next stage.
At a certain point you kind of hang up
most of your writing cap because you can
always rewrite if you're the writer,
but then you start to become the director
and start to think about blocking and
movement. And that was very,
very big deal in this film.
Can you define blocking just for
people who don't know? Yeah, sure.
Blocking is basically just how actors
move in a scene. It's all it is,
but it's really truly,
um,
a big part of the work because
for a lot of reasons. Um,
first you want to create blocking that's
organic and natural to what the actors
are doing in the scene.
So you want to make sure whatever the
actors doing makes sense with what their
objective is in the scene or what they're
doing in the scene or what they're not
doing in the scene or what
they're hiding in the scene.
So you kind of want to think about
what that, what that is all about.
Then there's a second tier,
which is as the filmmaker,
you're trying to make it
as economical as possible,
meaning as few setups as few times
to move the camera as possible.
Because every time you have to
sort of change where the camera is,
you have to change the lighting and that
just takes time and you want to get as
much time being shooting as possible.
So you're trying to figure out blocking
that works best for the simplest amount
of technical problems unless you're
really trying to do something technically
super challenging stuff.
So you try to balance those and you know,
and it's kind of a balance
because sometimes you will,
you'll tell the actor, oh,
can you help me out here with blocking?
Cause it means we have to do less,
but sometimes you don't want to get
in their way and you want them to be
creatively free.
So you want to give them
an open playground to play
around then where they can
do and move. So it's all, it's, it's,
it's a balancing act, um, but it,
but it's a big part of it. So
at a certain point, you know,
when the script is done,
and in the case of mother,
I was actually lucky enough to have a
three and a half month rehearsal period
where basically,
um,
I convinced Jennifer Lawrence and Javier
Bardem and Michelle Pfeiffer and then
Harris to join me in a warehouse out in
East Brooklyn where we basically taped
out the set and got,
we would work on the scenes and then
we'd get up on our feet and we would just
start the block then.
And then in the last two weeks of that
three and a half month long process,
I actually brought in my camera man
and we shot the entire movie moving the
camera around on video as
kind of homework and then,
which was really fascinating because
you figure out all different types of
problems like oh,
how's the camera going to get from it's,
it's a constant moving handheld camera.
So how am I going to get the camera from
here to there because there's a wall
there. Um, and, and that's,
that's suddenly started to play into
action. And for this film it was a very,
very restricted visual language.
I was part of the,
one of the challenges I
put in front of myself.
Normally you'll have a wide shot in a
movie and nice thing about a wide shot is
if an actor is somehow does something
that's not, that's like dramatically new,
emotionally new or if they decide to
comb their hair a different way in each.
If you go out to a wide shot,
the basically the illusion is broken for
a moment because the viewer's eyes have
to take in more or different part of a
scene or there's other things to look at
so that when you pop back into a closeup
you can get away cheap almost what's
happening and no one would ever notice.
In the case of my film,
since there was no wide shots,
it was extremely challenging.
I mean the only shots in the film
are you the over Jennifer Lawrence,
his shoulder on Jennifer Lawrence,
his face or her point of view,
which means what she's looking at. That's
the only coverage in the entire film,
so that's why this edit has been,
you know,
almost a year long cut because I had
such a limited amount of language to work
with and I had to make every moment by
moment by moment work even though that's
not really happening in real time.
Why did you choose to use that constraint?
I find,
I feel like I could talk to you about
constraints and rules for a really long
time because you mentioned, yeah, exactly.
Just get progressively more belligerent.
And you talked about say having lunch
scheduled for after the difficult meeting
and then you have say,
shooting over Max's shoulder
and different ways of,
as you put it, sort of limiting your
visual palate. Why, why do that?
Well, I think, I think it coming out,
starting as an independent filmmaker
with very limited resources, uh,
makes you be very, very, you
know, try your, you strategically,
you have to figure out economical means
to basically take advantage of all the
limited resources you have.
So I ended up actually stylistically
creating techniques that actually turn
those limited economics
and to a stylistic choice.
So I've always been preaching that
boundaries are the most important thing in
any form of an art. You know,
I mean, when you're a painter,
you have the boundaries of a canvas
and the limitation of your, of the,
your colors.
Um,
and I think it's extremely important to
do the same in filmmaking, uh, and, and,
and to make real choices about
how you want to do those limits.
Sometimes they're self imposed.
I have less of the economic issues,
although always you, you have to be
very economically responsible for it,
for what you're doing. But I went really
extreme on this film, which was like,
I basically said,
there's three shots for every scene,
which is an incredibly low amount of
shots, but I would normally do, um,
in a movie. And it just became an
interesting exercise and experiment and,
you know, and there were times when
Maddie, my DP was like, don't you want to,
you know,
like never does a character come
between Jennifer and the camera.
Yeah. No one never crosses
the line. I noticed that,
which is crazy because when we're
doing crowd scenes with lots of people,
you know,
it would a lot easier to tell the story
by having Jen get lost in the crowd and
crowd come through. But no,
I was like, and my DP mad, he
was like, why? Why don't we,
it could be. And we talked about it for
a while and, and, uh, and I was like, no,
I think let's just remain Orthodox here.
Let's remain truthful to the intent.
And the one thing I was worried about,
people would feel claustrophobic
or you know, bored by the style.
And that doesn't seem to be the response
people are in seeing those limitations.
And I think that's because we just turned
it into a language and into a style
that people can understand.
Is there something you hope audiences
will respond with our walkout with?
Did you have an objective,
and this ties into I suppose the,
the genesis of the film as well.
I don't actually know the origin story.
Well the origin story is
hard cause it's murky.
I think it came out of
these endless headlines,
the endless stream of
notifications on your telephone.
The ability to scratch right beneath the
surface of our kind of civilization and
realize how many desperate and awful
things are happening around the planet.
It's still in this,
you know,
pretty enlightened time and there's a
lot of rage and a lot of helplessness
because like what can I do? How
can I stop this? And you know,
being an environmentalist when
we're completely under assault,
when you know what science
is telling us is going on.
And the same people that use their smart
phone every second and every minute of
the day of the people who say, well,
science isn't always right yet. This,
the product of science is in their pocket,
you know,
dominating their lives yet
refusing to see what's going on.
Like how could you not say, wow, there
might be some connection going on.
And I don't know. I come from a
science background and I, I, I, I,
I witnessed how little tiny,
small changes by men can deeply have
huge effects very quickly that are out of
control, you know, and then this
new idea of these feedback loops,
which isn't that new anymore,
but these ideas that are becoming more
idea that there's these tipping points
where things are just going to start to
accelerate. You know? And as a parent,
I just sit there and I
go, oh my gosh, you know,
I look at the beauty of my child and
want them forget about having a job,
having a freaking atmosphere and
having the ability to, I mean,
it's just crazy to ever think that, you
know, he'll see, uh, uh, really, uh,
an elephant in the wild and in any
type of wilderness way. I mean, I,
I, for the, for I guess,
I guess Prince William Sound was very
much wilderness when I was a kid and
something happened to me
when I was in Prince William
Sound. That was, I had a, um,
we were kayaking, as I said, for weeks,
and I was eating a granola bar and
the wrap or fell into the water,
it was like a foil wrapper. And I
freaked out. I like stopped. I tried to,
it just went right on there. And
because of the guilt of that, I still,
when I see trash on a beach, I pick it up
for that foil. You know, it's like that,
that guilt has carried me and I,
because at that time it
very much felt untouched.
Like I was the f one of the first
humans to ever experience it.
There isn't a place on the planet anymore,
not because of pollution only,
but because of climate change
that isn't effected by humans.
There is nowhere on the planet that is
true wilderness as it was 60 years ago.
You know, when I was, I was writing
a western and I realized, you know,
it was set in 1883 I think if every
single person on the planet disappear,
drop dead was abducted or
whatever at that point in time,
besides some forge metals, belt
buckles, horseshoes, bullets, guns,
everything, every remnant of humanity
would be gone in a century, you know,
completely gone because it was,
everything was built out
of earth materials and then
you suddenly have all these
freakish new materials where every single
bag of Lay's potato chip you have is
something that's around for 10,000 years,
longer particles that are part
of us and you can't escape it.
And so quickly from my childhood where
there still was places on the planet that
weren't really feeling any
impact to now where the,
it's all changed.
It's,
it's scary that people are just completely
denying it and turning their backs on
it. And out of that just, you know, I
just want to how it's like, you know,
I felt the Ginsberg howl and I just
wanted to Hal and I guess it's my how,
what is the Ginsburg Hell,
Alan Ginsburg, uh, the poem.
How got it. All right. Sorry,
I'm, they never read the
trading, my lack of it, you know,
show that way you should read. Oh, that
one's great. All right. Yeah, I mean,
but it's basically, you know, it
was a cry from the 60s you know,
of like what for his generation or
at least that's the way I took it.
How would you like people to go into the
movie and who should go see them now?
The obvious commercial answer might be
after everyone. Yeah. Well, I think,
look,
I think you got to know you're going
into a roller coaster ride and it's like,
you know,
when you get to the amusement park and
you see that loop de loop and you're like,
no freaking way, you should, you
should be ready for it. I mean,
yeah. And no matter how much I prep you
and Tim can tell you, it goes there, so,
right. I mean it's, it's intense and it's,
so if you want an intense different
ride, if you're, you know,
you want to see something different
at the, at the cinema, you know,
please come on down. Um, I, I
think, I think it's, uh, you know,
that's what we tried to do was make,
make a very unique rollercoaster. Except,
you know, it may go off the
tracks and into the concrete wall,
but I can't really be,
I don't want to be responsible for that,
but that's what happens.
But I mean, I just want,
I think it works on a lot of levels.
Um,
I was always like thinking was
going to be really scary and,
and you know, tilting into the
horror genre. You know, Jen Lawrence,
when she saw it actually thought it
was incredibly beautiful and moving,
that there was a beauty
to it. And, and then I,
and I've heard that reflected in a lot
of ways and so it's definitely not your
normal night at the movie. It's, but it's
the type of movie that you go see and,
and everyone will have something
to say about it, I think. Um,
and hopefully they're not too many
profane words directed in my direction.
Well, it could be profaned, but modifying
something good also. Yeah, there's that.
Yeah.
I'd like to ask about the sound.
So I have read that,
well,
a few things that a,
a lot of independent films or films in
general fail from poor audio quality.
That was a big thing I realized
very young in my career was like,
this is a pretty good movie, but
something's off. And it was always a sound
and the sound in this movie and in a,
and I mean in,
in more than one of your
films certainly is a very,
I'm searching for the right words,
but very visceral, very pronounced.
And uh,
I only read this other expression
after the fact after I saw the movie,
but that I think thinking
of music or the sound as a,
as an additional character. Yeah. Could
you elaborate on that? Because I've, I've,
I've never paid so much
attention to sound in a film.
I think it's a, well, you, you saw
a slightly unfinished, the only,
the first half of the film was
kind of Po really dialed in,
so it's going to get better.
I hope that's what we're supposed
to be doing as we speak. You know,
sound designed.
It for me is a huge tool and I got
totally turned on when I was a, uh,
a young kid.
I saw a documentary on the guys who did
the sound design for star wars and they
were out in the desert banging on wires,
making light saber sounds and it,
it blew my mind. I was
like, Oh wow, you know,
that's such a cool idea that you can
use any sound to do this and matching up
sound and image you
can really mess around.
So I've always been fascinated by
that. Um, but you know, since I move,
make these films where I really am trying
to make the audience have a visceral
experience with the character. In this
case Jennifer Lawrence's character,
I try to draw the audience into her
subjective point of view by you know,
creating a soundscape
that starts off realistic,
but then as things sort of shift and get
more and more insane becomes more and
more expressive and expressionistic Dick,
I love the fact that people are going
to be able to see this in theaters for a
lot of reasons.
And I want to connect this to
something else that I read about you,
which relates to the
historical lack of compliance
to widget making. Uh,
so the story
of you shooting Natalie Portman for Black
Swan in the subway at something like
three in the morning
without necessary permits,
without her having signed a contract.
How do you,
and I don't know it nearly as many
filmmakers as you do, but I know a few.
How do you get away with it? I mean
you, meaning you seem to be able,
and this is from the outside looking in,
but to make the art you want to make and
bend the rules or do things like that.
Why is that?
Are there certain sort of contractual
decisions or conversations you've had that
allow you to do it? Did you set the
precedent as like a problem child early?
So that's, they're just like, ah, it's
fucking Darren. So you get away with it.
I mean it's just the project.
I, I don't think, you know,
it's never meant to be
abusive. I mean, I don't know,
but I'm just saying, I think
that's the, the, the reality
is it's, it's not abusive.
It's about the work.
It's always about the work.
And I think if you can relay back to
that, but this is about, you know,
US bringing this to life and the
best way, and I think, you know,
there were people that would take that
line of argument and turn it into abuse
or, or push the line to something
that's not safe or fair.
And I think I'm pretty empathetic
to other people's feelings.
Maybe to a fault because I
think some directors in May,
it's kind of helpful sometimes to push
past some of that pain and be blind to it.
But that's never, that's just not
my character. I can't do it. I,
I feel when people are uncomfortable very
easily and it makes me probably better
as a director to read performance,
but it probably gets me less
than what I always need.
Cause I feel sorry sometimes I
have mercy cause and how dare you.
So, yeah, but you know, I think though
that, you know, when it's the work you,
you just, you go for it. And
people get excited by that.
And if you're actually
being truthful about that.
But there are times and places where
I've tried to do too much and people have
pointed out to me, hey
that's probably, you know,
it's not fair for these
reasons and I hear that and,
and then I just listened to
myself if that's the truth or not.
If you have that conversation and
doesn't feel true to you, is that the,
is that one of the primary causes of
walking from potential projects or like
what,
and I guess all of this is sort of
coalescing into a question of if you were
talking to a very promising new director,
let's say director, maybe
they're a writer, director,
but they drive and you want it to
prevent them from getting chewed up or
corrupted by the system.
Is there any particular career
advice that you would give to them?
It's a good question. I mean, I mean,
you know, just you gotta be doing, if I,
I'm always from the school,
you got to do it cause you have to do it,
but you don't have any other choice.
But to do it.
Just recently I ran into a film maker and
he was sort of complaining and whining
about doing a TV show because he really
wanted to be making films and that and
then,
but you know what?
My advice to him was not just stick
with your gut and do what you want.
I could tell he was a type of guy that
should be doing that TV show because I
could see like he was,
he was already past that point where he
had crossed and he was just going to,
so I was like, do it. But, but then
you find people who just, you know,
want to do what they do and you know,
and then you just want to support them
and give them as much love and support to,
to get it because they're trying their
hardest to do something that only they
can do.
Now does that mean,
for instance,
I've heard this advice
with writing that writing,
you should only write say a book if it's
easier for you to write the book and
then to not write the book. Like it has
to be that much of a kind of compulsion.
I don't think it's ever easier to
make a movie than not make a a well,
I guess maybe just sort of from a
personal right
pain,
pleasure standpoint.
Like I remember reading an
anecdote and I don't like it again,
who knows standard yet.
But about you,
I actually think this might
have been from the New Yorker,
a about a diary entry where you were
talking about a rave in Thailand and you
were like, the sun came up and
the people were dancing and,
and the sun came down and the people
were dancing and the tides went out and I
was miserable because I wasn't
making movies. Yeah, that's true.
That means you have to make
movies, right? I mean it's, I
guess so. I mean, I think for me it
was storytelling more than films,
although I think there would definitely
things in my past and experience that,
you know,
helped me.
Like very early on I got into photography
into black and white photography when
I was in junior high school and I would,
you know,
go into the dark room and
develop the film. I loved it.
And I don't know why
that fell into my lap.
It just so happened they had this lab
nearby and I was able to take a class
there and then I just started thinking
about photographs and taking pictures and
all that. So, and that
all led to this. Um,
but I think it could've gone any way.
It's funny cause when I was in college,
I didn't know what I wanted to do the
first couple of years I was in college.
I hadn't discovered filmmaking till
I was a junior in college. And, um,
and I remember walking around
hitting myself in the head going, oh,
I'm never going to find what I want. I'm
never going to find my calling, you know,
and then it happens for you.
Hopefully. And that happened for me.
I found something that I,
it was the first time I ever got
an a in college was filmmaking. No,
I was a B minus student until film
came along and suddenly, boom,
it was like something that kept me
out of my girlfriend's room. You know,
it was like, I'd rather be rather be
cutting the movie then laying in bed.
So I was like, um, you know,
I found it but uh,
I think eventually it comes and,
but it could have been a lot of things
I think. I don't think necessarily like,
I mean it's this weird kind of weird art
form and it could have probably come to
me in lots of different ways. It was
just something that I was like, okay,
I see a path,
I see something there.
And it's interesting and fascinating
and there's a lot to learn in there.
And so I just went for it.
If I were to ask,
say some of your closest
friends what your superpower is,
maybe you wouldn't talk about it cause
he seemed to be a pretty understated,
humble guy, but what your superpower
is or what makes you different?
What would they say or
what might they say?
I mean, my friend Dan is like, who's
doing those visual effects? For me it was,
I met him first day of Freshman
Year of college says, you know,
when people ask me, but he
changed. I say, you know what?
He was an asshole on college
and he's still an asshole.
But does my brother telling me that
that's an old breadth therefore it, yeah,
exactly. Exactly. I don't know.
It's hard. It's hard for me to say,
but definitely one of the best
things about my life has, uh,
as I talked about there is I
still hang out with the guys.
I went to nursery school.
I still hang out with the guys
I went to high school with.
I went to college with and um,
I think that that having the roots like
I'm into roots some into loyalty and I
think that's pro and I work with the
same filmmakers pretty much. And I think,
I dunno,
I had my friend Jed once said that the
guy who dies with the most friends wins.
I thought that was pretty good advice.
If I were to Pester your friends a
little bit more, give them a few drinks.
Yeah. And they get past the
obligatory, he's still an asshole.
If they're, if they got
to like the, the, the,
the point of drunk reminiscing and sort
of the emotional point of drunkenness,
what would they attribute your
success to? A Lot, a lot. I mean,
more people don't make it then make
it, you know, in the film business.
Ooh, it's a good question. Oh, you
attributed to, we could make it direct to,
I mean it's a combination. I mean, I had,
I had excellent parents, but you know,
almost always support me and always
told me that not to work so hard,
not to work too hard. You know, when I
would tell I got to go work, they'd say,
well, don't work too
hard. Was there saying I,
I mean that was after I got out of
college. So up to college they put,
they were both school teachers
and academics was super important,
but they also created a lot of,
um,
they created very good
responsibility and boundaries,
but also, um, didn't necessarily
create opportunities,
but gave me breathing room,
would support to find opportunities.
So I struggled in my twenties,
but I was able to struggle in my
twenties. Um, and so that, that was,
that was,
I think a big part was having that
type of support system and my sister,
so family was a major part of it.
And I think that allowed me to
have persistence, you know, um,
which I always say is nine tenths of
the game is persistence is, you know,
you gotta get up to the plate, you know,
to get that chance, to take that swing,
uh, and to get to the plate just
takes a lot of work. Um, but then,
and then when you get there,
it's preparation and homework.
Having done all your homework and um,
as well as you can,
as much as you can and then,
and then as you're taking the swing is
make it a responsible swing for the team.
You know, make sure that that
I, I love the baseball metaphor.
I wonder how much longer I can keep going
with your students. You teach, what is the
name of the class? I don't see, I mean,
I don't do it regularly because
I haven't found the best place.
I taught at Nyu for a bit and um,
a few other places. But I mean,
I just, I, I just to be honest,
I kind of wing it to see what kids are
doing. You know, I'll come in, I'll,
I'll talk to them about what their dreams
are, what their projects are. I'll ask.
They all sort of share. So I have them
all described each other's stuff. But I,
I love doing scene study with kids where
I have them put up a scene and bring
work with actors. Put up
a scene. Now this is a,
this is a scene that has
already peered, no, no, no, no.
I've seen from their projects,
they describe it to me.
They tell me what they want.
They'll put up the scene and then I'll,
I'll teach them, I'll give them my,
my direction on how I would block it.
I'll work with the actors,
I'll just show them my process and then
I'll pick a truck bought out and I'll
show them, let's see, how
would we, how do we shoot it?
And I'll just draw my designs
to show them how to draw.
So I give him a chalkboard is sort of
bird's eye view. Always bird eye's view.
That's how I've always, I, I came up,
I mean I know the filmmakers do it,
but it was when I was 1920
years old starting to do films.
That's how I started.
I always,
and it's probably from playing dungeons
and dragons as a kid, it was like,
you know,
you get that sky view and like I drew
little triangles and I came up with all
these different shapes and forms.
I have my own like language that I've
developed over the years for how to do it
and I have the ability to look at that
architectural plans and then to see it in
three d below so I can,
that's how I do it.
I do it very much from a bird eye view.
Dungeons and dragons will
be for round two. I was,
I was always a chaotic
good cleric Plus Gray Elf.
Elf. Yeah. You're a cleric. No, no, I,
I don't remember that. Well actually,
I mean we played for ever, but I
don't actually remember my character.
I'll bring some graph paper next time.
If you were to,
this is related to the class, let's
just say you could no longer make films.
Right.
And your sort of divinely assigned to
mission was to coach five five to 10
filmmakers.
Yeah.
And not only would you get the
psychic reward of seeing them do well,
but much like say who bankroll
is a poker player,
you would get a percentage of the future.
What are the things you would focus on
if you had say, a six month period? Well,
I mean if I was doing that
and I had a share of it, yeah,
I mean as soon as you bring the share
into it, it's like a, all right,
so that we could, we could, we could, we
get approached as a couple different ways.
So one is you get the profit share,
it's like a 50 50 split with them.
Plus you have a kicker, but you have to
add some money. All right, we can do that.
I would never do that. I this is
this only investments. Awful invests.
This is force. That's what we have
huge Chinese companies for it.
But the other could be really whatever
reward you would want to get out of it.
So it could be the acclaim and
receiving awards and prizes and so on.
It could be anything else.
But I mean really,
I mean the, the real, I guess,
I mean the gift of any teachers to see
whatever the goals of the student are,
as long as they are righteous
goals be achieved, you know. So,
you know, I would probably want to
teach students that were, you know,
probably had just wanted to tell good
stories and then I would want them to see
them,
make them as well as they could and then
have them connect with as many people
as they could. The awards, the
money, that's all silly stuff.
I mean,
it's great for everything,
but it's really has as many
issues with it as good things.
So, um, I mean it's,
it's just you want to find people and I'd
want to find students that really just
want to tell stories and entertain and
they not that they want to be a filmmaker
quicker because where the rock star of
the present day or the NBA basketball
player of the day, you know, where it's
because that's what they want to do.
Like when I started telling stories,
it wasn't like when I was a kid,
no one knew what Spielberg did.
We heard the name Lucas and Spielberg.
But that was it, you know, but
not really, you know, no one,
how do you become a director?
And when I started to do it,
even in the early nineties,
it wasn't really,
it was early Sundance days. It wasn't
really this track record of how to do it.
So I wasn't like looking for
the reason to be, you know,
that it could lead to
something that was clear.
It was just something that was
interesting and fascinating to me.
So at this point when there are
all these paths too, you know, um,
fame and money and all that and you know,
if you make one film you can go and do
a marvel movie or something like that,
which is happening all the time now.
I think you want to find people that
are looking to tell the stories and then
help them tell stories. And like when
I, the last class I taught at Nyu,
my best student was a Turkish kid who
was going back to Turkey to tell a small
story about an apple tree on the,
on the,
on the side of mount are at that
starts a village fight and tiny story.
It could be huge,
who knows?
But he was serious and you
just wanted to tell that story.
And so I gravitated to him and I spent
most of my time in the class working with
him to help him because he was the guy
who was going to go make a movie and was
serious and knew what he was doing.
And I said,
let me focus on this kid
so the other kids can see,
be inspired by his path.
Any
top scripts, if somebody has never read
a screenplay and you're like, look,
just start,
start with a
BC. I mean, the guy's working
today, Eric Roth, Scott silver,
read any of their scripts that great
writers. I'm Chris Terrio. I mean,
there's a lot of great writers working
right now. I mean there's, there's,
there's a lot of good, great
scripts that I've read. I mean,
Charlie Kaufman scripts
are great and fun to read.
It's enough to start with. Yeah, I think
so. Where can people find the film?
Where should they learn more about it?
I've never had something. Yes, exactly.
And I've had just for everybody listening,
I highly recommend you check it out.
Like Darren said, like, no, you're
signing up for a roller coaster.
And uh,
but I've had nothing
produce this really unique.
I'll get yelled at for modifying unique
by someone I know, but that's okay.
I'm going to just for him,
very unique,
a dreamlike state for about 18 hours
afterwards. It was amazing. Yeah,
it was really profound. But
where can people learn more
about it? Well, I mean it's
mother with a low case.
I'm in an exclamation point,
which causes all different
type of difficulties with
social media because of the
exclamation point. But, um, I mean
by the time this comes out, I hope,
uh, it's going to be
around, um, if not, um,
you know, uh, that, I mean just
Google mother movie and you'll,
you'll be seeing a bunch of bat it out,
I hope.
Where can people,
if they want to check you out on social
media or was that something else?
Full name Darren Aronofsky ad on
Instagram and a Twitter. Yeah,
that's, I, I, you know,
Instagram is pretty cool. I've
been doing this cool thing.
I don't know if you've been following it,
but I found two young film students
and they were moving out to go to film
school in La and I rented them a big
projector and a cube truck and they'd been
driving through the country,
projecting the word mother in different
languages onto all different types of
structures around the country.
And so I've been posting these,
emit these beautiful images that these
young filmmakers have been making, um,
to help sell, promote my
film. But also, um, it's,
it's been a fun project to learn about
all these different places all over
America. It's kind of humans of New
York, is that humans have, sure.
Is that the name of the Cummins in
New York? Humans of New York. But, um,
more projections of mother.
Very cool. So people can say hi to
you on the interweb, check it out.
Any last,
uh,
asks or recommendations of
people listening besides
seeing the movie? I mean,
just keep, uh, keep seeing
the weird stuff. Go out and,
you know, let you know, support when
you, and then spread the word, you know.
So I think, you know,
if you dig the movie,
get it out there and get
everyone to go see it.
I'm hoping that it's type of film that
you'll want to talk to other people about.
Well, I will, I can attest certainly
with two people I saw it with,
we talked about it for hours afterwards.
So one of the things I
really enjoyed his head,
this is not follow the typical template.
Any typical template.
Yeah. And that I can, that I can see.
So it leads to a lot of conversation.
Dare to be different, dare
to be different. Well Darren,
I really appreciate the time. Thank
you to Sam. It's an amazing, yeah,
this has been really fun and
we, we can, we can keep going,
but I want to let you get
back to his film. Yeah,
well then polishing up everything
and to everybody listening,
you can find links to everything
we've discussed, including the movie,
the books and so on in the show notes at
tim.blog/podcast as per usual and every
other episode. And until next time,
thank you for listening. Bye Bye.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share
the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's
four hour workweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in your email and
you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which I've used for many, many years.
I absolutely love audio books.
And there.
One of my favorite ways to
pass the time when I travel,
I'm on the road all the time and audible
allows me to consume many more books
than I possibly could otherwise I have
to audio books to recommend right off the
bat. The first is perhaps my favorite
audio book of all time and it's the only
audiobook I've wanted to
listen to twice in a row.
The graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
It's amazing and you will thank me.
There are a few different versions.
I like the version that
Neil narrates himself,
one of the most soothing
voices of all time.
The second book is vagabonding
by Rolf hots, p, o t t,
s which had a huge impact on my life
and formed the basis for a lot of what
would later become the four hour workweek,
so go to audible.com forward slash Tim
and you can choose one of these two books
or any of many,
many other options that could be books,
magazines and much more as a
listener of the Tim Ferriss show,
you can also access a free 30 day trial.
Just go to audible.com forward
slash Tim you can't make more time,
but you can make the most of it,
so turn your travel or your commute
into something more with a free trial at
audible.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim to
start now and get your free 30 day trial.
This episode is brought
to you by wordpress.
My goto platform for blogging, writing
online, creating websites, everything.
I love wordpress to bits.
My site,
every site just about that I have is run
on wordpress and the lead developer of
wordpress, Matt Mullenweg has
appeared on this podcast many times.
The very first episode in particular is
amazing. Second, I took a ton of notes on,
so he's checking out, but
wordpress, where do I even begin?
I mean the New Yorker uses it,
Jay z, Beyonce, they use it.
Five 38 tech crunch, Ted, CNN.
Time with you're looking to create
a personal blog, a business site,
both, neither. Something else.
You'll make a huge impact when you
build your website on wordpress.com and
directly from some friends at Google.
I'm not going to quote them by name,
but they say that wordpress offers
the best out of the box SEO.
That's search engine optimization
imaginable, so if you're on wordpress,
you immediately have a leg up on everybody
else on search engines and so forth.
In my experience, I'm no medical
doctor of search engine optimization,
but I will say that I used wordpress
for years and it fell in love with it to
the extent that I became very close
friends with Matt and then became an
investor slash advisor to automatic,
which runs wordpress.com that is how much
I believe in this and that's how a lot
of my most successful products and
investments have come about because I'm in
love with x and then I seek out x.
Nearly 30% of the Internet
is run on wordpress and that
includes everything from
the huge sites that I mentioned to
neighborhood sites and it is super easy to
get started. There's no need to worry
about security or upgrades or hosting.
They offer 24 seven support
and handle all of that,
which allows you to focus on creating
the highest quality content you can with
the least amount of friction.
I don't have to worry about downtime.
I don't want to have to
worry about getting emergency
emails if I'm on vacation
or something like that, and wordpress
is my goto solution for all of this.
I trust all of my most important
text on the Internet to wordpress,
and they can't buy that with
a sponsorship. They can't
buy that with anything.
I want uptime, uptime,
uptime, and quality,
and that is what I have selected
after everything that I've looked at.
So check it out.
Go to wordpress.
That's w o r d p r e s s.com wordpress.com
forward slash Tim to receive 15% off
of your website today.
That's wordpress.com forward slash Tim.